I I wonder that constantly I you know
whether it's the the op-ed pages or you
know or the the internet you know
women's voices are out there but they're
not you know they're not put out into
the mainstream and they're not brought
to the forefront and I do think that's
part of systemic sexism like I don't
think that there's a guy behind a desk
at every newspaper saying no woman like
and sending her on her way but that's
what's a stomach about it right like
that people don't quite realize that
maybe they're attracted to a male off
add more than a female off a door
because of you know networking they know
this person from going out to a bar with
them you know there's there's all sorts
of reasons I think kind of day in and
day out that influence that sort of
stuff and I also think that right now
online especially there's this trend of
kind of having women's websites or you
know women only spaces which I don't you
know I go back and forth on you know
obviously feminist thing is kind of a
woman's space in a certain way even
though we have a lot of male readership
and people who don't identify as women
and so there is a kind of an upside to
it but I think to a large degree when we
kind of separate ourselves out and it
furthers the notion that women's issues
that there are such thing as women's
issues that these aren't everyone's
issues that women's issues are special
issues or special interest issues or
we're bringing in the gender card well
when men talk that's the gender card too
you know so I'm just really wary of all
of this separating out
that all of the websites for women you
know and I'm thinking specifically of
like corporate websites and you know for
women are really consumer-driven they
are they do really assume that all women
want to do is shop and you do it well
and shop and shop and I I don't think
it's surprising because i think it's
recreating the same paradigm that you
see with a lot of women's magazines or
that you see in real life or with
advertisements or with with TV but i do
think that we have this incredible
opportunity because you know being
online internet is a relatively new
space we do have this incredible
opportunity to change that dynamic you
know to make sure that that women are
present in all sorts of spaces not just
women only spaces i mean i think a part
of that is going to have to be making
you know general public spaces on the
internet a bit safer for women you know
if you go if you go to you know places
like youtube it's it successful and a
lot of the the comments are really
horrifying and and misogynist and
harassing and i think that you know
online harassment has become so
ubiquitous on the internet that a lot of
women do you feel safer whatever that
means of in spaces where they know it
like people are not going to bother them
in that kind of way I'm talking about
the internet generally when you whenever
you hear something about sexual assault
right if there's an article about sexual
assault if there's a video about
feminism on youtube you're going to get
the most horrible disgusting comments
ever and sometimes the comments are
pornographic and sometimes the comments
are really harassing and so I think that
it's kind of a difficult place for women
to to write sometimes I mean the
Internet is the new public space right
and because women are out in public
people don't like that in much the same
way that you know if you're walking down
the street you know you get harassed I
think the same kind of thing happens
online and I think that's why a lot of
women are hesitant to put their voice
out there there's been
all sorts of story is that there was a
kind of a infamous incident happened a
couple of years ago when a technology
blog earn called kathy Sierra her life
was threatened you know she had people
posting photoshopped pornographic
pictures of her and this has happened to
me and this has happened to a lot of
feminist writers I know when you put
your voice out there in a really public
way or you're saying something that's
stronger you're saying something that's
political or you're saying something
that people aren't necessarily used to
hearing women say people get really
uncomfortable and because folks have the
anonymity factor and they don't have the
same kind of accountability that they do
in the real world they're much more
likely to say really horrible disgusting
and scary things and there's only so
many you know rape threats you can get
before you start thinking hey maybe I
shouldn't be writing
I think feminism is taking off it's just
not visible in the way that we would
like it to be you know I I do think that
there is a real crisis of masculinity
that's that's happening in America I
think the problem is is the way it's
being framed is that there's a problem
with masculinity because women are too
powerful or women are taking up too much
space and that's the way that it's being
talked about rather than what's going on
with men you know that maybe they're in
school less or that they feel like they
have to adhere to a you know a certain
ideal of what men are supposed to be
like and so instead of focusing on men
and focusing what we can do to prop them
up people seem really incredibly focused
on the fact that women are doing well
and maybe that's not such a good thing
I think that I think that it is
effective when activists work from from
the margins in i think that's that's the
best way to go about it ab and i do
think that it's increasingly being more
effective with the work that's being
done online that it is a bit more and
democratize that you know whatever kind
of maximum activism is being done it's
not necessarily coming from one
centralized place one feminist
organization isn't saying okay go out
and change the world or go out and you
know organized around this while they
are doing that they're doing it in
conjunction with other groups that are
doing it in conjunction with other blogs
you know small blogs are starting up big
campaigns I think that's a that sort of
really a step in the right direction and
because you are getting more voices out
there and maybe while one organization
is you know focusing on one aspect of an
issue you know you're they're focusing
on abortion right another organization
is saying okay but what about birth
control another organization is saying
okay what about you know sterilization
and the right of women to have children
you know so just the idea that you know
all of these different voices can be
working on the same issue but bringing
something different to the table I think
is really important
the what bothers me the most about the
way that people appropriate feminist
language is that there are the same
people who are you know anti-feminist
the same people who say that feminism is
ruining the family yet when it becomes
them to you know they'll they'll say
sarah palin's a feminist but you know
when all of a sudden it it works in
their favor and i think that's that's
really upsetting to a lot of feminists
but it also is really dangerous in terms
of how the word becomes water down and
who gets to use that word and who gets
to use that word for the work that
they're doing and you know something
else that's really happening that I've
noticed and this is happened with like
third wave feminists is that people seem
to think because of the way that the
media has appropriated third-wave
feminism feminism or young feminism that
all young feminist or about is like pull
dancing and girls gone wild and how
empowering it is like they'll start
calling anything feminist I saw an
article about a year ago where the the
manager of the pussycat dolls which is
kind of this like striptease and ban you
know girl band said oh well you know the
girls are totally third wave feminist
this is what third-wave feminism is
about like you don't get to use that
word you don't get to to say that
something is is feminists you know as a
way to sell back sexism to women as a
way to you know further consumerist
ideas it's it's really incredible but
it's really effective right like it's an
incredibly effective tool one of the
funniest things I saw was that you know
the fastest growing form of plastic
surgery is the designer vaginas the
labiaplasty Xand the replaced hymens and
all of this sort of stuff and if you
look at the press releases from a lot of
these places they use feminist language
they say things like women now have
equal sexual rights so cut your labia
off you know it doesn't really make
sense but they know that that's a great
way to get women to think that their
woman friendly and you see that a lot I
think
I hope not but yes yeah I do I mean I I
think that the the election and watching
sarah palin and and hillary clinton and
the way they were treated was a really
really interesting moment you know and
it was bad for both of them you know
it's as much as I disagree with sarah
palin there's there's no denying that
she was the victim of sexism over and
over again in the campaign but what you
kind of saw happening was that both
sarah palin and hillary clinton filled
these you know models of femininity like
whereas hillary was like the the
ballbusting you know what was it the
take out that her voice reminds me of
taking out the trash she was like the
ballbusting man hater and Sarah Palin
was the male friendly like sex symbol
and neither of those are really great
you know accurate realistic nuanced
complex models of what it means to be a
woman or what it means to be a woman in
politics um but that's that's what they
were stuck with and I think that we're
going to continue to see those kinds of
narratives when it comes to women in
powerful positions that people aren't
comfortable thinking of women as people
right like we're not people were women
and that means something completely
different especially when you have power